in this game the vast world of Hyrule
reaches High into the sky
you'll notice some land masses floating
up there
we call them Sky Islands
you're probably wondering something how
do you get to the sky islands when
they're so high up
there
if we take a look oh something's falling
from the sky
see it
I wonder what that is let's head over to
it
we are almost at the spot where the
object fell
here it is
okay let's use one of Link's new
abilities
if you do this on the rock that just
fell
look it started Rising
this power is known as recall which
rewinds an object's movement
since I just used recall on the Fallen
Rock I can now rise into the sky we're a
lot closer to the sky islands
let's use the paraglider to reach one of
them
there are a few other Sky Islands
floating here too
I made it
there are lots of ways to reach the sky
islands so we hope you'll try a few
different methods there are even more
new abilities
take this building over here okay watch
this
look I passed right through the ceiling
this new ability is called Ascend if
you're in a place with a ceiling you can
go through
bit to the floor above you
there are some restrictions but what's
great about this ability is that as long
as there's a ceiling you can use it
anywhere
for example this place has a cave with a
hill right above it
if we use the Ability here
come on keep going
okay we emerged at the top of the hill
in the previous game you had to use
stamina to climb a mountain but in this
game if there's a mountain with a cave
like this one you can now get to the top
without having to climb all the way up
here's another example imagine you're
stuck in a cage if it's got a ceiling
you know what to do right exactly